[Music]
today we canceled probably not for the
first time mid-tier squad member rashida
talib we last saw rashida in an
interview on axios explaining why all
federal prison inmates including sex
traffickers and child rapists should be
immediately released from prison
the idea she was hawking on the house
floor this week isn't or last week
rather isn't quite as bad as that but
it's almost as bad
it's a bit more mainstream anyway and
that is student loan forgiveness
but the interesting thing about rashida
rashida's pitch for student loan
forgiveness is that she is herself a
perfect example of why we should not
forgive student loans
listen for yourself
i worked full time
monday through friday and took weekend
classes to get my law degree and still
close to two hundred thousand dollars in
debt
and i still owe over seventy thousand
dollars
and most of it was interest
most of it was our own government making
money and profit off of me
and guess what i didn't go to the
for-profit entities i went to legal aid
i worked at the non-profit organization
fighting for you know the right to
breathe clean air to fight for the
worker that was getting their wage uh
you know taken and stolen from their
employer i went and worked on immigrant
rights and so much more
and all of that to say
we have to stop treating as if folks
that are paying for education as if they
bought some bougie car or some big you
know something beyond no
they were seeking an education
okay so rashida talib wants debt
forgiveness and uh she complains that
she still has 70 grand left on her loan
which was originally 200 000
for a law degree she says a degree that
she's chosen not to use she admits that
she immediately took that degree that
cost her well into six figures to attain
and went off to be an activist at a
nonprofit
now she's a politician
fortunately for her she makes 175 000 a
year in her current job
which raises the question why should the
taxpayer assume her debt when she earns
an income more than double the national
average
the fact that elected representatives
earned more than double the national
average is a separate issue entirely i
mean i think that they should get paid
they should get paid the national
average income that's what i think
um
for now though the point is simply that
she she chose the most expensive
education path possible now she rakes in
a sizable salary and yet still insists
that the taxpayer fulfill her financial
obligations for her
the appropriate response to that
argument to that argument is no
pay your debts you damned deadbeat
now i'm glad that rashida talib has
wanted to make herself the face of this
issue because she is the face of it
as an affluent upper-class brat with a
graduate degree she does indeed
represent a large portion of the people
clamoring for debt forgiveness in fact
people with graduate degrees account for
half of all student loan debt
half
that's because the average amount of
student debt for bachelor degrees is
only about 30 000
not insignificant but manageable
the way that we get to into trillions of
dollars collectively
in terms of debt is through all of these
people getting master's degrees where
the average debt is 70 000 and law
degrees and medical degrees where the
average debt is 150 and 200 000
respectively
so when you hear about debt forgiveness
just know that half of that money money
that will come from the taxpayer from
you will be going to upper class
affluent highly educated doctors and
lawyers and so on
student debt forgiveness is upper class
welfare that's what it is you're looking
for a great uh christmas gift for
yourself or for someone else cammy cotto
knives are the way to go kamikoto makes
great
japanese steel kitchen knives using
traditional techniques from japan
kamikoto taps into more than 800 years
of traditional techniques from honshu
japan kamikoda also only uses steel
sourced from mills in japan and each
blade is crafted using techniques that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths i feel
powerful holding these blades in my hand
each knife comes in a beautiful heavy
duty ash wood box which you can see
right here i'll try not to stab myself
in the face as i point the box up
and make sure that the knife is stored
safely it also makes kamikoto a great
gift each kamikota knife goes through a
rigorous 19-step process that takes
several years from start to finish to
complete our uh expert bladesmiths forge
and shape raw steel into hardy blades
polishing and sharpening them to an
excruciatingly fine edge each knife is
individually inspected chemical is so
confident about their knives that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee
because of their single beveled edge
i just look at those very sharp edges
chemical knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge that you just
can't get with other knives they can cut
through rib eye like butter kamikoto
knives are used by several chefs working
at michelin star restaurants so click
the link below or go to camcode.com matt
walsh and use promo code matt walsh to
save an extra
50 off today of course i realize that
plenty of people with graduate degrees
are not doctors or lawyers
um some of them are not getting paid
well at all the you know the two years
master's degree programs are largely
useless
an enormous scam
and many people today are walking around
with graduate degrees that serve no
purpose whatsoever and there's been no
return on investment
contrary to sleep's claim they are
indeed like
you know basically getting a bougie car
those graduate degrees they're
superfluous extravagant useless showy
at least you can drive cars you can't do
anything with mostly graduate programs
but even so who should be on the hook to
pay for your superfluous and useless
graduate degree you or your neighbor
really if we wanted to talk about debt
forgiveness for the middle class for
average working-class americans we'd be
forgiving mortgages or credit card debt
or car payments
that's the kind of debt that most people
deal with most of us don't have a 200
000 slip of paper sitting in a frame and
hanging on a wall in our office
maybe the student debt forgiveness
proponents though would say sure yeah
let's forgive all that debt too
but that only that only proves that
they're a bunch of mental children
they have no understanding of or
appreciation for the financial realities
of life
they think a magic wand can be waived to
solve all these problems even as the
government's magic wand that it waved
over the last two years has led to
skyrocketing inflation and an economic
situation that's even worse than the one
that these measures were supposed to
solve in the first place
when it comes down to it this this is
again
a question of
who should be responsible for the debts
that you take on
if you enter into a contract
and agree to pay x amount for y product
or y service
who should be the one to hold up your
end of the bargain and there are only
two possible answers to that question
you
or everybody else
you might prefer the latter option
everyone else but it's not justifiable
on a logical or moral or financial basis
i'm sorry if you went to a master to get
a master's degree so you could teach the
abc's to first graders
i'm very sorry that such a terrible
decision has caused you heartache i am
but my well of sympathy dries up the
moment you turn to the government and
ask it to point its guns at me and reach
into my wallet to solve your problems
you immediately go from being a
sympathetic yet silly figure to a thief
now all that said i do agree that our
approach to higher education is
untenable
and that's why i think we need to
evaluate that approach rather than
simply trying to get rid of the debt
while leaving the fundamentally broken
system still in place
okay so this is this this again like we
talked about the left is just like solve
the homeless price crisis by putting all
the homeless in hotels
yet they're still mentally ill drug
addicts
so we solve our broken higher education
system by just forgiving
all the debt but the system is still
broken
the solution to the debt crisis going
forward the way to staunch the bleeding
anyway and make sure it doesn't get
worse
is to stop sending our kids into
four-year institutions by default most
of them don't need to be there and won't
gain anything of lasting value from the
experience
if there was a massive drop-off in
enrollment and we encouraged our kids to
be more discerning about the choice to
enroll in college and we push them to
explore other options aside from
four-year institutions
then many of these problems will begin
to sort themselves out
colleges for one thing wouldn't be able
to charge lamborghini prices for degrees
if they had to compete not just with
each other
but with the whole array of other
options that the world presents
if only people would explore them before
signing up for the college path
that's the point that rashida talib
ignores or outright it rejects
she wants to keep the spigot turned on
siphoning millions of kids into the
university pipeline whether it will
benefit them or not
only she wants the government to be even
more involved in funding and
facilitating the whole disastrous system
so as usual she has it all exactly
backwards
and for that she is
canceled well i hope you enjoyed that
clip from the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content